[音楽]
ん
こんにちは
私は
昨年3月まで
安城市城南町の町内会場でした
13年間町内会等努めてきました
13年ですよ
長いと思うか
まあ物好きにと思うか
なんか人にこのこんなことやるあのてあげられたらと言いますけれども
まあ身内ですから明日聞きます
ところで
今日この会場昭林公民館は
城南町内会の
エリア内にあります
ですから今日私はあ
地元で
好き子をさせていただける
感謝です
皆さん
町内会はどんなことをやっているかご存知ですか
町内会は
日本に振るくる古くからある
住民の組織で
住民によって
運営されております
そこでは
守り継がれてきた
伝統
とか文化とかあるいは祭りとか
人と人が
フォレ青稜所等しコミュニティを築いています
私が町内会長になって
最初に取り組んだことは
小学生児童の登下校を見守る
スクールパトロールでした
14年になります今年で長いですよね14年です
そして始めた当初メモっていた
消費税等も今や性獣をして街で会えば声をかけてくれ
時には
立ち止まって話を進めることもあります
そして城南町ではまた
様々な
悩みあ相談をか相談事を抱えた方が巧妙になり
町内会の方にお目になりますそんな時私どもあ
実際に
そのが動いてその方サポートしながら問題のヶ月
あたっています
具体的には
私の家へ
視覚障害者の方が
ゴミを出してほしいとかこんな電話で依頼があります
また
町内の中では1人暮らしで外に
だからここで不精な高齢者の方が見ますそんな所は私ども出かけていって
雑談をしながらその人の悩みを聞いたして対決していく
あるいは
町内の中にも認証の方もお見えになります
歩いていらっしゃいます散歩してるのかあるいは徘徊してるのかよくわかりません
ですからとりあえずは一緒になってその方について歩き
そして自宅まで送り届けるとこんなこともしております
これは
このような取り組みも私どもは町内会の一つにやっぱりだというふうに私は考えてい
ます
以前の町内会はこのようなことを取り組んでいませんでした
私は町内会長になったんだっ
最初はですねこんなことをやろうなというふうに考えませんでした
実際に取り組みをしませんでした
それは私が
定年になった時の自分の夢は
家内と車で日本を一周するという
こんな夢を持っていました
10年経ちました
でも出発することができませんでした
プーマはポストなっちゃいました10年といっ
そして2台も買えました
書いたクロマグロくらいになります未だに出発できていません
ですから
今度は
私は76になるんです
ですからもうそんなクルマに乗って日本一周なってできません
今度私の月れてしまいました
そんな私が
地域の福祉に
関心を持った感謝を持ったといいますか最初に取り組んだことは平成18年10月です
が
私ども町内の中で
60歳の男性で一人暮らしの人が
購読するということがありました
8日間
誰も見つけることができそのままでした
私は本当にショックを受けました
それは
私は町内会長としてその方が病弱であったために両隣の方はじめ go 近所の人見
守りをお願いしていました
そして私も変わって見守っていたわけですがそんな中で孤独死をされてしまったんで
私は自分が孤独させてしまったと思いが私の中で強くそういうものがありました
そして
再び
町内で孤独者出さない地域づくりをどのようにしていこうという風に考えましたけど
なかなかわかりませんでした
ひょっとすると
みなさんの周りのそのような方お面なんじゃないでしょうか
でもねお若い方ばかりですからなかなかそういう形にお目にかかることはないかもしれ
ませんね
ですがそれを時皆さんだったらどうされるでしょう
私は
平成19年
安城社会風刺空海吉村良子さんの
相談しそして
支えマップ作りを
やったらどうだということをすすめられました
で実際に取り組んでみました
支えマップというのは
町内の中を
いくつかに地域は文化史ブロッカーしてきます
いくつかのブロックができますそのブロックの中にさまざまな課題を抱えた1名になり
ます
印象の方も俺はあるいは障害者も目になります
あるいは基礎暮らしの方もメダルそれを
マップの中に落とし込んでいきます著
てい
その問題をみんなで話し合いながら
マップを見ながらみんなで話し合いながら1つと取っ解決いる
こういうことを私どもを行ってきました
ですから私どもはこの支えマップ作りを始めた時に
町内会員の皆さんはこのようなことまで町内会出してくれるんだということで安心感を
持ったようです
そして現在は
町内会の方にですね直接相談にプルようになりました
それは私ども支えマップを始めた一つの成果だというふうに私は思っています
このような
チーク手がうち曲集を進めての中でねー
地元の西川小学校から
私にゲストティーチャーとして学校生きて子供いい
委員長の問題
あるいは高齢者の問題を教えてほしいという依頼がありました
そしてもちろん私はそれを
受けさせてそれを業界してい
実際に学校行って
6年生の児童に
認証の問題と
磯村し高齢者の問題
加えて支えマップの問題お話をさせてもらいました
児童は一生懸命私の話を聞いてくれましたよ
そして私の話を聞いてくれたい児童がいい
今度は自宅や帰って
お母さんとその話をしたようです
お母さんと話をされた内容を
学校の方に出し親子の会話ということでアンケートにされたものを後5学校から見せて
いただきました
その中で書いてあったことは
認知症は恥ずかしいからご近所に明らかにできない
プライバシーはご近所にしてに一人知られるのは嫌だなっていうのはことは母親の声を
書いてありました
子供の声としては
民商の人を
じゃあどうやって探すの泊したのはどうやって探すノートようなことが書いてありまし
た
私は
子どもたち子どもたちに
認証の問題あるいは
一つかして問題笹薮の問題というのは
ひょっとしたらそういう地域福祉の問題たら難しいのではないかというふうに実は思っ
ていました
でも実際に事業を始めてみたら子どもたちは私の話を真剣になって聞いてくれました
私はここにこの子どもの学ぶ姿に
感心したというのか感激しましたまあある意味でまた競技の素晴らしいたってのもある
んですよね
そんな思いが
ありました
そしてそのような
結局士の勉強をしている中ねー
終わった後
町内会に
表面を持ってくる町内会活動に興味を持ってくれる生徒さんがいました
そんなかな
6名の生徒が
ジョン6という
そういう
まチームを立ち上げて
町内会を
をて際食用になりました
私はその女宿さんぜひ上そうな子だったんですよ女の女性とはですね
ま
その子たちがどんなことをして町内から手伝ってくれるのかっていうのは正直言って
疑心暗鬼でした
ですがあるときその
上6のメンバーが町内会規程高齢者の集まりに自分たちで
昼食を作って振る舞いたいということで町内会に来てくれました
ちょっと待って歯まだ6年生の子がそんなことできるのと授業気持ちならそんなんあっ
たんですよ
でもほんとに
数字つ5
6人のメンバーが来て
料理を作って
そして
高齢者の方に振舞ってくれました
そして高齢者とともに一緒に食事をしながら会話をする
私は
子どもたちがひょっとしたら
喜んでもらえるとかあるいは面白いかなと
入れたんじゃないかなとそんな風に自分ではそんなふうに思いました
しかし子供たちは
実際に自分たちで振る舞って高齢者と話をすることで自分たちはちゃ
町内会のために役に立ってるいうふうに思ったようです
ですから
その所塾のメンバーが
また後日町内会規程何か手伝うしてください
何が消灯いらしてくださいん
こういうことを言ってきました
そして私は島人廃刊寸前になっていった
私どもの候補してん
あるんですか
その後方証発行してみるかというに子どもたちに問いかけてみました
そしたらやりますやらせてくださいということで実際に即行動です
何分かの広報ショー彼女たちが作り上げ
そして現在も
その候補者ですね廃刊にならず
発砲されています
町内会人
子どもたちがかかることで城南町のお祭りは
させたいのすわー
参加するようになりました
子どもの参加すれば親も参加します
そして日頃は腰の重いおじいちゃんもおばあちゃんも参加して
そうした子どもたちに声をかけながら軽やかに動き回っています
私は
子どもたちが
将来地域で起こりうる問題を
一緒に
話し合いながら解決してくれる
存在になるだろうということを私は期待しています
それをたちが
将来町内会をそのようになってくれる
存在になるだろうというふうに私はその結果月病
することができました
しかし
これから
若い人に
いろいろお願いしていくとしても
その若い人って言うのは
今
町内会を
引き継いでプレイ分若い人です鼓動じゃありませんので
町内会費ついてくる若い人に
これから
知事でもらいたいと思っています
しかし
私たちがやってきたことその若い人に押し付けるんだよな
わかる人若い人の感性を持って町内から続けてくれるいいだろうと思っています
また私たちが私たちが入っ同じことをやらなくても
子どもたちが
将来を超える地域の問題を
一緒になって対決できる
糸駆除作ってくれるだろうというふうに思っています
皆さんの未来あ
子どもたちの豚あるいは認証の方も障害者の方も
地域での支え合いながら
ピッ
このしていける
コミュニティについて
考えて行きたいと思います皆さんも一緒に考えていきましょう
ありがたい車
[拍手]